et pour en parler nous sommes avec
jacques mignaux gilet jaune
bonjour monsieur gillioz merci d'être
sur notre plateau alors on le voit les
manifestants sont déterminés à voile à
défiler pardon les lieux de pouvoir
pourtant ce sont des mots interdits par
la préfecture de police de paris
pourquoi vous êtes déterminés à passer
par ces lieux alors qu'ils sont
interdits on est déterminés à passer par
ces lieux parce qu'il ya plus de
légitimité à manifester devant ces
lieux-là et interpeller nos gouvernants
les sénateurs les députés etc plutôt que
par la population elle-même qui est au
courant que ça fait bientôt quinze mois
qu'on défile samedi après samedi et
c'est eux qu'on veut vraiment touché ce
qu'on veut vraiment interpellé
on veut vraiment engager la discussion
avec eux qui viennent à notre rencontre
et qu'on puisse instaurer un débat qui
est qui qui commence à parler avec nous
puisque ça fait plus d'un an
nous on n'a eu aucune réponse aucune
mais à chaque fois que des
manifestations passé justement par des
lieux de pouvoir on a vu une répression
assez violente des forces de l'ordre
justement la préfecture de police craint
des débordements
ce n'est pas une crainte pour vous ces
débordements justement à écouter samedi
dernier on était devant le conseil
d'état
ça s'est très très bien passé je pense
qu'ils ont les effectifs nécessaires ils
sont vraiment très très large déployés
sur le terrain donc je pense que s'il ya
des débordements ils sont quand même en
capacité d'intervenir rapidement et de
cibler les éléments qui seraient venus
pour pour mettre des troubles donc
moi je vois pas quelle peur ils peuvent
avoir ils sont quand même la brave ils
sont quand même les crs les gendarmes
mobiles
la bac enfin ils sont quand même
beaucoup d'effectifs à leur disposition
une mobilisation qui s'affaiblit un de
semaine en semaine puisque la semaine
dernière vous étiez pas très nombreux en
tout cas dans la capitale
comment est-ce que vous expliquer ces
chiffres qui baisse on n'était pas
nombreux pourquoi parce que quand on est
arrivé devant le conseil d'état
on s'est fait menacer voilà on était
entouré de forces de l'ordre ensuite
donc on est venu remettre l'interdiction
de manifester à mon ami faouzi donc
ensuite la dispersion a été votée par
les manifestants on a essayé de se
disperser on est de nouveau menacé après
alors qu'on circule librement dans la
dans la capitale donc effectivement bas
il ya les gens ils ont peur et puis ils
rentrent chez eux
donc ça s'explique aussi par là il ya
notre mouvement une autre mobilisation
on va dire parallèle a cédé gilet jaune
c'est celle
de la mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites qui connaît énormément de
succès lundi 17 on est encore un nouvel
appel à une manifestation nationale
au départ vous étiez pour manifester aux
côtés justement deux de ces personnes
qui sont dans la rue maintenant depuis
plusieurs semaines il était question de
convergence des luttes est ce que c'est
toujours le cas aujourd'hui
la convergence s'est beaucoup fait mais
d'un seul côté et ça on le déplore et on
les appelle à venir aussi avec nous
chose qu'ils ont du mal à faire le 20
février normalement ils nous ont
appelé à une grosse manifestation ou en
fait tous les syndiqués ont demandé une
grosse journée à ce qu'on vienne aussi
mais on leur demande aussi également
s'ils veulent qu'on fasse un pas vers
eux il faut qu'ils sachent en faire un
vers nous c'est très important parce que
ça fait partie de notre futur pour nos
enfants pour nous aussi et c'est donc
oui effectivement c'est très important
qu'il y ait cette convergence
nous on n'a jamais fermé la porte mais
par contre on leur demande de venir vous
l'a demandé de venir mais est-ce que
vous pensez que votre combat est le même
que le leur au final c'est la même chose
ce qu'on fait depuis plus d'un an et
demi c'est quelque chose qu'ils auraient
dû faire depuis bien longtemps puisque
c'est leur rôle prépondérant en tant que
syndicat ils sont là pour rassurer nos
droits sociaux pour assurer nos salaires
etc
ils n'ont pas été capables de le faire
jusqu'à maintenant
donc on leur demande de venir nous
prêter main forte ce qui est tout à fait
leur rôle merci beaucoup en tout cas
jacques mignaux d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes j&j
merci à vous